[Music]
this is mount gox one of the earliest
bitcoin exchanges in the world from 2011
to 2014 mount gox dominated every
bitcoin exchange on the planets at one
point it was responsible for 70 of all
bitcoin transactions on earth a true
monopoly but because it was a monopoly
if it went down it would bring the
entire bitcoin ecosystem down with it
and that's exactly what happened almost
out of nowhere the entire site went dark
in 2014.
very dramatic
unexpectedly shut down today mount cox's
twitter account is deleted its owner
resigns from the bitcoin foundation and
it's announced that 850 000 bitcoins
have disappeared from the sites stolen
by hackers at the time 850 000 bitcoins
were worth around half a billion dollars
450 million to be exact today that would
be worth more than 28 billion dollars
not surprisingly mount gox goes bankrupt
soon after and bitcoin's price it drops
to its lowest in years
at the time this cataclysmic event was
considered the end of crypto there was
no way the market was going to recover
from this and immediately people started
suspecting foul play whoever pulled off
this robbery was now halfway to becoming
a billionaire just like that and
everyone pointed the finger at the
site's owner mark carpellis
but fast forward eight years later and
mark carpellis is still innocent
so who was behind the first major crypto
hack in history well it turns out
there's a lot more to the story than
meets the eye
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime of my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
starting right now we're picking a
random instagram follower every single
week to win you just have to be
following me at jaketren just got this
new handle and you're automatically
entered watch out for fake accounts i
will never message you asking for money
and this is the mystery of the mount gox
billionaire
[Music]
this is jed mccaleb the creator of mount
gox
way back in 2006 when the mount gox
domain name was first registered jed had
no idea what the site would become
his initial plan create an online card
trading platform for the magic the
gathering game all right i'm going to
play a fifth mana card and then i'm
going to attack with my elder beast can
can he block his elder beast not with
his shapeshifter it's already tapped
four damage to your planeswalker
no
the original card game had just launched
an online version and jed thought it
would be cool to create a site where
people could easily buy and sell their
online cards pretty simple right the
site's name magic the gathering online
exchange or mount gox
well fast forward a few months and jed
gets bored of his newest project and
puts it on the shelf he would use the
site a few more times in the future for
personal projects but mount gox wouldn't
come back to life again until 2010.
that's when jed comes across an article
about bitcoin still in its baby stages
jed realizes there's no standard way to
trade buy or sell bitcoins
well
why not use the same setup he had going
for magic the gathering but just use it
to trade bitcoins instead of playing
cards
jed had a feeling that bitcoin was going
to be a big deal and this was his chance
to get in on the ground floor so
on july 18th mount gox comes back from
the dead this time as a bitcoin exchange
things go well for a while but then jed
gets bored again according to him it
wasn't technically interesting and he
just didn't have the time to keep the
site running smoothly so in early 2011
jed sells mount gox to our guy mark
capelas a french programmer and fellow
bitcoin believer
it immediately took off like
much faster than i thought it would and
then i realized that at the u.s there's
all these regulations you have to apply
with
there's a there's a lot of legal risk
around like money transmissions jed
essentially sold it to the first person
he found
mark capelas would be the man to take
mount gox into the biggest exchange in
the world
mount cox was the first place where you
could
turn your fiat currency into bitcoin it
was the exchange there wasn't really an
alternative this was the mount cox was
the bank of bitcoin essentially
you had like 98 of the world's market
share if if you think of bitcoin as
being an island
at that time mount cox was the only
bridge to the rest of the economic world
and this is where things get interesting
[Music]
if you're watching this channel you're
probably trying to be very successful
one day and a lot of people think the
key to achieving success is always
grinding but that is not the case the
most successful people know that 90 of
this game is mental and a big part of
that mental game is working through all
the mental issues childhood trauma
relationship issues that we are all
plagued with and the best way to do that
is with a therapist and looking back i
really wish someone would have pushed me
to go to therapy sooner i used to be
super awkward because of all my
insecurities in childhood trauma and i
could have gotten over that way sooner
and easier if i had some help i would
have been happier sooner i wouldn't have
wasted so many years and i would have
been more successful sooner but the
problem is finding a therapist in your
area is really hard but you're in luck
because that's where today's sponsored
betterhelp comes in betterhelp is the
largest therapy platform in the world
with over 2 million users that is
democratizing therapy with better help
you'll have access to over 20 000
licensed and vetted therapists all
online and this is not a crisis line or
self-help it's professional therapy that
is done securely online and it's super
easy to sign up just give better help
some information about yourself and what
kind of therapy you're looking for then
based on your needs better help matches
you with a therapist that is the best
fit for you and then boom that is it you
start communicating with your therapist
in as little as 48 hours and once you're
matched you can message them whenever
you want and then you can set up weekly
video or phone calls with your therapist
to avoid the awkwardness of in-person
meetings and if you're not feeling your
therapist it's simple and free to switch
to a new one plus better help is more
affordable than traditional therapy and
financial aid is available so if you're
ready to start taking control of your
mental health head over to
betterhelp.com for 10 off your first
month that's
betterhelp.com for 10 off your first
month thanks to better help for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
what was mount gox's biggest problem in
2011 it was too successful
no one not jed or mark could have
expected the site to blow up so quickly
thousands of people were logging on to
mount cox every day to trade bitcoin and
mark capelles was in way over his head
transactions were overwhelming the
system security updates couldn't keep up
with the amount of people signing up and
just four months after mark buys the
company from jed it gets hacked for the
first time
the hackers gained access to a mount gox
employee's computer and used it to steal
25 000 bitcoins at the time that was
equal to around 400 000
with so many huge transactions happening
the bitcoin price dropped to one cent a
few hours later a hacker called c
razzlestinger puts the entire mount gox
database up for sale and people use that
info to steal even more bitcoins
throughout the day it took mark and his
team a full day to block the hackers out
and get things back to normal
but even after the first hack and all
the security issues it exposed people
just couldn't stop using mount gox it
was too convenient and with the price of
bitcoin stabilizing again everything
just went back to business as usual but
this hack was just the beginning
[Music]
mark should have taken that first hack
as a warning of things to come
but according to other mount gox
employees he wasn't exactly a hard
worker instead he didn't really seem to
care about any of the security breaches
or hacks mount gox was facing
mark told the world that everything was
going to be fine but behind closed doors
nothing in the company really changed
there was no urgency all the while mount
gox's popularity just kept growing
by april 2013 mount gox had a monopoly
on the world's bitcoin transactions
handling 70
of all bitcoin trades this meant that
the price of bitcoin and mount gox's
popularity went hand in hand for a
system that was supposed to be
decentralized bitcoin was looking
extremely centralized
on april 11th bitcoin prices were rising
so quickly that mark announced a trade
suspension for 48 hours so the market
could quote unquote cool down and the
prices could stabilize
one single man practically froze bitcoin
at his whim
but for now everything seemed to be
working relatively smoothly it seemed
like there was nowhere to go but up
by may 2013 mount gox was trading over
150 000 bitcoins per day with one
bitcoin costing just over 100
but then
things turned bad
fast
[Music]
[Music]
mount gox unexpectedly shut down today
one of the world's biggest bitcoin
exchanges has found for bankruptcy mon
cox
hundreds of millions of pounds and
prompting the sharp fall in the value of
the currency i felt like i had been
punched in the stomach and i couldn't
believe that how could you lose 800 000
bitcoin starting in late 2013 weird
things started happening to the mount
gox website it would go dark at random
times often for hours at a time whenever
this happened the price of bitcoin would
drop once the site came back online the
price would go back up
by november 2013 most us-based mount gox
users were waiting weeks or months for
their cash withdrawals to process
something wasn't right but people were
still holding out hope that the mount
gox team would get things back to normal
bitcoin was going up from
it was hanging around 100 140 for a
while then it stayed around 200 for a
bit then it just started shooting up it
was just rising like crazy so went 120
240 and just kept going up and up and up
and suddenly it was a thousand dollars
i'd be in front of my computer just like
kind of cheering on the price it was it
was great
uh
yeah i go to the gym to work out and i
couldn't stop looking at my phone right
tracking what was happening it was it
was a wild ride and so at the end of
that month uh november
i think the price was around 1200 or
something i i didn't really want to sell
my bitcoins yet but i wanted to get them
back off mount gox after trading i asked
for the coins back and it was a slow
response it was actually my birthday i
remember it very clearly i was in paris
in a hotel i don't know why but i was
thinking i really should withdraw my
bitcoins from my gox i went to my
computer and
started a withdrawal and i checked an
hour later and they hadn't come out they
told me i needed to verify my account
which they never asked for before uh
when just dealing in bitcoin to receive
a bank wire they'd want it and that's
when uh things started to go
downhill but by february 2014 the
website's issues just got worse
february 7th all mount gox operations
are stopped the reason a bug in the
bitcoin code most of mount gox's
competitors also paused their
transactions while the bug was corrected
but unlike them mount gox didn't come
back online the next day as the days
went on and people couldn't access their
money or use the site things started to
spiral mount gox users were panicking i
don't expect their company's going to
last much longer i think it's about to
collapse
and i expect that no one's going to get
the money back but we'll see mark
cappellas didn't have anything to tell
them other than there would be new daily
and monthly limits on withdrawals once
the site was working again we'll work a
little bit anyway in the meantime we're
sorry for the
uh
troubles goes like this and then it
happened
23rd 2014 disaster hits mount gox
mark capelas resigns from the bitcoin
foundation and all mount gox's tweets
are deleted
february 24th the mount gox site goes
offline
customers are redirected to a blank page
with no information about what's going
on
just before it went dark the bitcoin
price on mount gox dropped from just
over 1 000
to around 100
is this the end of bitcoin that's what
everyone around the world was afraid of
millions of dollars of bitcoin was being
stored in mount gox's wallets how would
any of it get back to its rightful
owners now
days go by with no word from mark or his
team
few days later a document has leaked
claiming 744 000 bitcoins had been
stolen from mount gox users plus another
100 000 of the company's own bitcoins
[Music]
850 000 bitcoins nearly half a billion
dollars poof
disappears into thin air
four days after going dark mount gox
files for bankruptcy
mount gox makes a big show out of
quote-unquote looking for the stolen
bitcoins and even manages to find 200
000 of them in an old wallet in march
but it's not enough in april the company
is liquidated
from the biggest bitcoin exchange in the
world to an embarrassment and failure in
the space of just a few months
people were angry
someone had to be responsible and right
then all the signs were pointing to our
guy mark capelas himself
[Music]
almost immediately after the hack was
announced people started suspecting mark
he had never really seemed to care about
other hacks and his work ethic wasn't
exactly great
had he bought mount gox from jen mccaleb
as part of some plan to scam people out
of millions of dollars
at first mark isn't charged with
anything people suspect him but there's
no proof that he was involved but then
in 2015 mark was arrested in japan where
mount gox was registered his arrest gave
people hope that their money would soon
be found obviously the smart guy was
guilty if they just pushed him a little
the cops would probably find all the
lost money well japan kept mark in
solitary confinement for almost a year
they interrogated him for months and
followed every lead that they had but in
the end even japan's police and court
who are notorious for always finding
people guilty had to admit that mark
wasn't their guy
in the end he was charged with altering
company records to make it seem like
mount gox had more money that it
actually did illegal yes but did he
steal the bitcoins no
his negligence and mismanagement had
ruined one of the biggest crypto
companies in existence but he wasn't the
one who had stolen the money the cops
would have to keep looking
2016 two years after the hack the mount
gox database is handed over to us
authorities and they start trying to
track the stolen bitcoins down
the trail leads them to a russian man
named alexander vinik alexander was
involved with a bitcoin exchange called
btc-e
and according to the cops around 90 of
the stolen bitcoins could be traced to
wallet he control
he may not have stolen the bitcoins
himself but he did use
btc-e to launder him alexander vinik is
arrested while on vacation in greece and
indicted on 21 charges connected to
mount gox that's not even counting his
other charges like drug trafficking and
helping the russian government's team of
hackers fancy bear hack the democratic
national committee as soon as he's
arrested france and russia start a tug
of war over where he gets extradited to
france wins and alexander is sentenced
to five years in jail for money
laundering the investigators had found
the guy who laundered the bitcoins but
they hadn't found the coins or the
person who did the stealing but it gets
deeper the investigation against
alexander had led the u.s to a
surprising discovery remember the first
hack that stole 25 000 bitcoins from
mount gox in 2011 well that hack and the
leaked database had given someone the
opportunity to slowly steal 850 000
bitcoins from mount gox's hot wallets
over the space of three years
it seemed to have been that between
autumn of 2011 and towards uh to the
middle or the even the end of 2013 there
were bitcoins stolen in chunks
over time
almost continuously
throughout that entire period we have no
idea exactly how they were gotten into
the systems maybe some combination of
social engineering or just plain hacking
or
compromised code or
something but first and foremost
to do this particular theft you need
patience because
they've been doing it over
years
and quite slowly and deliberately and
been quite careful in how to move the
bitcoins out afterwards hot wallets are
the wallets connected to the internet
that mount cox used to run the exchange
what this all means is that it was
actually the first hack that started
everything
for three years someone had been
stealing bitcoins from mount gox without
mark or anyone on the team noticing how
do you not notice your 850 000 bitcoin
short well mark was constantly inflating
transaction numbers to push the bitcoin
price up so something like that is easy
to slip by but that's where the trail
ends today there's still no one that
knows who stole the 850 000 bitcoins or
where the money is now if the cops have
suspects they aren't making them public
because it's an ongoing investigation
whoever he is if he managed to keep all
of the bitcoin he would now be around
the 50th richest known person in the
world an 11 figure billionaire
hope you guys enjoyed the video and if
you're new here my name is jake and we
make documentaries just like this one
every single week on money power and
crime multiple times a week for free so
if you like this one click that
subscribe button below because you can
always dislike and unsubscribe whenever
you want so you might as well do it and
if you want longer documentaries that
are so controversial that i can't post
them publicly click that join button
below we just put out a documentary on
the bin laden papers basically all the
documents that received when the navy
seals killed bin laden super interesting
video that would definitely get the
monetized because it's on bin laden at
911 all the things youtube doesn't like
and you can watch it right now by
clicking the join button below and
there's a refund policy so if you join
and you don't think it's worth it you
can email me and i will personally
refund you the money that's going to
wrap it up stay dangerous out there and
i will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you